[Music]  these two-dimensional sheets of plastic  fold themselves into 3d shapes when  activated by light researchers printed a  series of shapes on two sheets of shrink  film when exposed to certain wavelengths  of light the underlying polymer heats up  causing the plastic to fold along these  color hinges flashing types of light in  sequence allow the sheets to fold into  complex shapes red ink responds to green  light cyan ink reacts to red light and  yellow ink to blue light the sheets can  also be designed to react differently to  the same wavelengths by using various  hues of the same color darker hues react  to the light more quickly built in shape  programming like this may have the  potential to be used in implantable  medical devices smart packaging or even  in deploying satellites  [Music]  [Music]